how's it going best might as Pierrette
about welcome back to mad father we're
gonna go in the laboratory and see what
Maria can I have your cookie Maria
mistress you're wounded yes but it'll
all be fine
forget me escape somewhere safe it is
dangerous here where's father I heard
him screaming for my room yeah I must
save the doctor
oof
you can't go with that wound but Maria
what happened to father the doctor is
father in his wife she what his wife is
my mom Maria main Maria
triple dot Maria my it seems she passed
out oh the plot thickens
it's Slenderman you again at any rate it
would seem like your father has gone on
ahead deeper into the underground maze
huh
but did Maria see mom passed away right
what's going on here don't tell me the
curse you'd only be able to confirm your
suspicions by pressing on Mancha
Slenderman what the [ __ ] what a weird
guy guy had no swag yah blow the shelves
are a mess
hell no [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] blood
everywhere goddamn can I take this torch
with me because I would like a torch
right now what about your bag it stinks
like your mama filled with blood Maria I
wake the [ __ ] up can I slap her as I'm
Shing Maria
well we're pressing on whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa let's and I expect to
find him right away oh oh well her tits
are still nice
mom value y no way was that really mom
there's no way I mistook her that was
mom what was even mom it must have been
a curse right haven't you noticed this
tragedy was brought about by the power
of a woman's caste the melodies for your
father that malice turned to a cat's
seeking out your father stack could that
woman be so you do realize yes your
mother is stupid I can't be why do you
think that because mom loved father mom
even understood father's work and father
loved him in return wasn't mom happy I
can't deal Billy I couldn't believe she
was had a grudge against father well he
cheated on her but maybe mom didn't like
father and Maria maybe maybe but don't
want it to be true but I don't want to
be true I can't read I'm sorry so you'll
go find the truth triple quad net ball
dot that was a jam though I want the jam
let's all just slap my ass
who did that I got the gam what's up man
moving no longer you mean not moving
whoa that is Bonnie kick not brave
enough oh [ __ ]
oh yeah are we gonna invest so we need
to find her body is it this one I don't
even know
I got promised to shut up what's going
on here dynamites what the [ __ ] what
it's totally someone there crow a cron
what the [ __ ] the ladder the ladder
we've been looking for breasts boughs a
bag barrel the [ __ ] are you done one
what is going on a crazy what happens
over here more bad well uh what if [ __ ]
am I going sub crates
unlock the door it's a shortcut back
perhaps I was a hidden passage well
wonderful
what's with the lag croakin okay I think
it's over here I'm not sure bras yeah
I'm sure now right let me restock
alright yeah now it's better how about
you use your ladder now that what that
what that I got a gem
filled with junk what down you go
what's up what do we got why don't we
get there is ashamed on a minute change
ah ha ha ha
what there's a special key to equip
chainsaw it can normally only be
equipped in the basement when you quit
crest confirmed key to make is well
confirm key is Zed all right and special
keys see I remember firing sculling me
for playing with this once she likes to
play with chainsaws I always serious
what a [ __ ] messed up family ha ha ha
come on now girl
oh yeah what are you doing swinging that
thing around sorry
I just wanted to kill paper this is not
toy it's a very dangerous tool
understood never play with anything like
that this again sorry father
I'm glad you're not hurt it is odd
though I thought this would be out
somewhere that was out of your reach
where on earth did you find this I I'm
sorry I'm sorry father
ha just shut up already
I like that he doesn't even take it away
all right well we have a badass chainsaw
now she will say oh thank god
I'm not not run gone
oh let's kill some zombies it's Samba
smack in time
it's amber smack in town its ambit smack
in town while that's how I smiled I
forgot
it doesn't look like I can use it here
though you're perfect yeah oh I felt
like someone grabbed my leg
whoa Paranormal Activity crown woman
always put it down
I'm push it push a goddamn that [ __ ]
song man all right
I can't use my can I use my chainsaw
head no I can I wanted to kill you guys
but I guess I'll way fiend did that
Aladdin all right whoa sorry about that
what ma'am ma'am ma'am killer virus whoa
whoa what the [ __ ]
I got a gam run mmm mmm ma'am mmmm die
die die
you didn't just move them you got it you
got to [ __ ] murder them this is best
game ever hello grads what's up my
murmur I'm Ram RAM RAM it's a fake
motorboat I mean Jane so nice I got a
game now whatever I got to talk to you
go get Tata crabs crabs crabs there we
go the old man mumbles himself curse at
doing every safe I so deceived as to
true nature it's going to create she's
even crazier than a doctor hmm well
whatever
what should I care I supposed cool story
bro you want something fella you want
something barrels I got a [ __ ]
chain saw with that with that with that
this is a castle crow [ __ ] sorry I
nearly chains on you
what's that what that ooh creepy what
does this go it won't happen
oh hello friend not from the inside girl
what I can't say can't see anything that
man took away my eyes Oh bro I'm sorry
about my where's my chainsaw
I want my chainsaw smells like alcohol
pile of wine kegs spilled wine bottles
are you sure about that
well something there spline ball how do
I get past here I need to get unlock the
door storehouse what is this oh we're
back here okay so now I can actually
walk through here fair enough
whenever went down here I think
all right here's something look wow
that's creepy
okay oh those looks like eyes Oh
disgusting take the eyes take take take
the eyes it's clearly Horace I'm serious
just take them what what what what's
your problem woman but finally thank you
about your love they fell out all right
quite squats Monday we have a bucket now
good I love buckets you fill them with
[ __ ] I love filling [ __ ] I felt I feel
so good feels so good buckets I don't
have your head but maybe I can change
saw you whoa hello whoa whoa whoa all
right all right
fight me stay away gosh stay away back
up spawn of Satan come here
wrong way wrong direction come here come
on
yes saving people good note found it
nice nice going bro you want some glue
with that thanks mrs. welcome you're
welcome
and it pooped out again that's nice I'm
brave enough you don't think I'm brave
enough huh you don't think I'm tough
enough huh well I tell you whoa what the
[ __ ] was that [ __ ] man calm down all
right so now we have her her eyes and
hopefully she will open the gate and
everybody can skate and I will be happy
I press um I'm pretty pissed because my
[ __ ] webcam yeah stop working it's
been doing that lately I don't know why
the way it's gone now
it's completely devoured the covers a
mess no not anything but everyone chill
chill down it's not a party unless it's
a pity pie party anyway we need to go
here I've already played this
unfortunately because the webcam crashed
it's only this part pretty much where
you going no way where is there I don't
even remember I'm such a genius here it
is um I was feeling like super genius
for fingering this out I was like oh my
god I'm so smart but now you don't even
get your name even get to realize that
sensational thing you'll just be like oh
cool he just did that
alright so I have the wallet but I first
tried to do was put it down that it
didn't work I've tried to put it that
didn't work try to put it here didn't
work and I was like I'm not gonna have
to put this water everywhere and I was
like put it there didn't work and so
what I did was I was like oh my god I
could put her to my goats put a day and
then I did and it worked but then
something happened that I did not expect
it looks like I could walk inside a
fireplace and then I walked inside of
fireplace and I was amazed by how
pixelated everything was all the sudden
but then I realized I'm hearing the same
sound of that girl with the eyeballs and
then I realized I should probably jump
down there
then I realized I could just throw them
down there this is goes down into her
room I could give her these eyeballs
cool
give her the eyeball bottle there you go
friend right in her head
nailed it we kill her good job you're
now a murderer
I'll uh make you feel huh sup zambese
we're on the same team now I think it's
a shortcut to go here
I haven't unlocked it yet I'm so stupid
oh wow [ __ ] happens right the Mohnish
thing oh yeah I killed you
hahahahaha alright so yeah we're just
gonna go back to the girl and that's
pretty much where I left off um last
time so I don't I don't know what's
gonna happen further beyond this point
which is a little creepy I don't know
how she walks through there but she does
it and here we go hello I found my eyes
that's core not the correct voice I
found my eyes that's problem oh [ __ ] huh
she's actually kind of yeah she reminds
me of that girl from the M the evil one
I can see I can see hallelujah Oh maybe
not that good after all what you gonna
do thank you oh she's so happy
ah I thought she was gonna come with us
I was kind of looking for with that
alright pull this lever and we're gonna
save and we're gonna go in here let's go
in the venture into the unknown of mad
father I have a chainsaw
don't you dare [ __ ] with me what I came
back to where I was before barrels are
you [ __ ] with me what in the hell
what care that what is that ah [ __ ] it
probably wasn't there before
uh-huh barrels stop it stop it barrel
all right what do we got
um are you keeping me from going in yes
I need to go through here to say my
father
it's a place let me go through what can
I do to convince you kill the bowels I
could do that huh it's coming with me no
get up got got a cat chaser she's really
impeccable skills of following people ah
Sh what what what are you doing stop are
you following me
do you want to go home fine where's your
home you want to go out and party you go
to a nightclub I see come with me I'll
take you outside then let me through
here okay all right cool it's over here
crow [ __ ] it's outside jump what did she
fall behind well at least we got rid of
her
oh oh
how the hell huh this is triple dodged
question mark huh hi these are the girls
clothes what's going on why my butt what
ha what ha ha no we got to see what her
dad did hmm they still want you what
further that chainsaw is awesome
nice no father what are you no
Stefan it's me double excavation point
I can't spank Oh No I don't even get to
see it come on huh dramatic zoom in
double dramatic zooming track ball
dramatic Somen oh [ __ ] it's mad all
right trip a lot quite nipple dot all
right anyway knock video didn't know it
subscribe over a day and I'll see you
next episode of I ll make everybody else
him aha
throw him in a ring were wandering
around the mall no it
yay
and the Eagles awesome reference